l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion en
lecture définitive du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 la parole est à Madame Élisabeth
born première
ministre madame la présidenteadame id de
la commission des affaires sociales
madame la rapporteur générale mesdames
et messieurs les
députés nous arrivons au terme de
l'examen du projet doit de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 je veux profiter de cet instant
pour saluer le travail remarquable
accompli depuis des mois par la
présidente Charlotte Parmentier Lecoq et
par la rapporteur générale Stéphanie
Rist je veux
remercier remercier les députés de la
commission des affaires sociales qui ont
permis d'améliorer ce texte je souhaite
saluer les députés de la majorité qui
ont fait des propositions et défendu nos
convictions même face aux mises en cause
et parfois au hurlement je veux
remercier l'ensemble des parlementaires
qui ont accepté de participer aux
concertations lancées par les ministres
Aurélien Rousseau et Aurore berger pour
trouver des points d'accord et enrichir
le projet de loi remercier les
parlementaires qui ont déposé des
amendements
constructif des propositions de la
majorité comme des oppositions figurent
aujourd'hui dans le texte ce PLFSS c'est
un budget de 640 milliards d'euros pour
notre modèle social ce sont des moyens
en hausse pour notre santé pour
l'autonomie des personnes âgées et des
personnes en situation de handicap ce
sont des solutions d'accueil pour les
jeunes enfants ou encore des
rémunérations revalorisées pour nos
soignants ce texte renforce notre
sécurité sociale
nous en avons besoin aussi sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement sur l'ensemble du
projet loit de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre l'Assemblée nationale
prend acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 49 aléa 3 de la Constitution
le texte sur lequel la première ministre
engage la responsabilité du gouvernement
sera inséré en annexe au compte-rendu de
la présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alignéa 1er du règlement
le débat sur ce texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de censure
déposé avant demain 15h05 et votter dans
les conditions prévues à l'article 49 de
la Constitution dans l'hypothèse o une
motion de censure serait déposée la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et les modalités de la discussion la
séance est suspendue je vous
remercie